et cette entité aujourd'hui c'est vous
michel debiard cas bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
sociologue directeur d'études à l'école
des hautes études
en sciences sociales vais y arriver et
vous signez cet essai alors monsieur
macro heureux en essai qui est paru aux
éditions rue de seine au lendemain du
second tour de la présidentielle qui
interpelle le président est réélu sur
son bilan et qui dresse des lignes pour
2027 il n'a pas vous me le confirmer
michel wieviorka été imprimées dans la
nuit du 24 au 25 vous aviez fait un
petit pari sur l'avenir oui j'étais
convaincu depuis plusieurs mois qu'il
serait réélu et mon éditeur m'a fait
confiance le livre était prêt mais je ne
voulais pas peser sur la campagne
présidentielle
on va y revenir dans un instant il ya
cette question que pose le titre est la
question que j'ai envie de poser à
l'homme publiquement de gauche que vous
êtes michel wieviorka alors que la
france soumise est en passe de réaliser
un tour de force celui d'unir toute la
gauche pour les législatives du mois de
juin on attend fébrilement l'accord avec
les socialistes dans les heures qui
viennent alors michel wieviorka heureux
pas vraiment pas vraiment parce que tout
ça a un petit côté lente agonie qui
s'achève peut-être du parti socialiste
et donc une partie des socialistes sont
vigoureusement opposés cet accord
l'autre se dit que quand il n'y a pas le
choix que faut savoir mettre
de l'eau dans son vin si je peux dire
bref c'est pas un accord pleinement
satisfaisant mais il faut pas non plus
comment dirais-je est totalement négatif
donc j'ai des sentiments mêlés qu'est-ce
que cet accord qui découle bien sûr de
la position de force de jean luc
mélenchon 22% et demi à la dernière
présidentielle dit du niveau de
recomposition politique en france mais
elle dit qu'elle est fragile parce que
c'est un accord qui met en avant des
preuves acquis qui crée des problèmes en
particulier sur des grands dossiers le
nucléaire en particulier l'europe
l'europe et donc c'est un accord qui
nous dit ce qui va se passer à gauche
c'est une dynamique fragile si elle se
met en place vraiment je noterai
d'ailleurs au passage que l'extrême
droite va pas beaucoup mieux non plus et
donc si vous et que ce qui va se passer
au centre avec emmanuel macron est
problématique
donc ça nous met vraiment dans un moment
où des dynamiques nouvelles peut-être
vont se mettre en place mais où une
énorme fluidité possible et d'ailleurs
la fluidité des violences et du chaos
dynamique fragile mais
pour que la gauche
sauf à écouter si elle doit se
reconstruire comme ça si vous aviez
qu'elle se reconstruit à partir de son
extrémité de ses dimensions les plus
radicales en quoi emmanuel macron est
responsable de ça je pense que la
principale responsabilité d' emmanuel
macron c'est d'avoir voulu tout au long
de son mandat premièrement de n'avoir
pour adversaires lors d'un deuxième tour
à la présidentielle qui vient de se
passer marine le pen est donc d'avoir
voulu accompagner dans leur
affaiblissement qui lui devait pas tout
bien sûr mais d'avoir voulu accompagner
le déclin de la gauche classique et de
la droite classique ça c'est sa première
responsabilité et on fait le vide je
dirais que ont fait le vide aussi dans
d'autres domaines dans mon livre je je
parle aussi de questions plus
intellectuel ou idéologique sur les
histoires disque à mogo schisteux walkie
cetera certains des proches de manuel
macron ont voulu qu'il n'y ait personne
entre le pouvoir qui incarnerait la
république et les extrémistes et donc on
la mine si vous voulez et deuxièmement
dans cette logique là la deuxième
responsabilité de d'emmanuel macro c'est
d'avoir affaibli des corps
intermédiaires qui vous demandaient pas
mieux que de l'accompagner on va y
revenir vous dit autre chose dans ce
dans ce livre donc que la france souffre
de la concentration des pouvoirs vous
évoquez à l'instant à fortiori quand le
président à la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale ce qui est le cas ce qui sera
peut-être le cas à nouveau après deux
mois de juin aller ou revenir vers un
vrai régime parlementaire c'est ce que
propose précisément jean luc mélenchon
avec sa sixième république est-ce que
c'est souhaitable selon vous qu'est ce
que ça changerait concrètement alors moi
je ne suis pas un acteur politique donc
ce que je souhaite moi c'est que le
débat s'ouvre je ne suis pas certain que
la formule 2 monsieur mélenchon soit la
meilleure mais il faut que le débat
s'ouvre sur nos institutions il n'y a
pas que la question de la constitution
et d'une éventuelle sixième république
qui est posée la question de la
proportionnelle est posée est ce que
nous allons élire nos députés à la
proportionnelle comme l'avait demandé
françois bayroux il ya déjà plusieurs
années ou pas ça comme un allié puissant
d'emmanuel macron acquis la promesse
avait été fait et ce que nous allons
maintenir deux quinquennats pour le chef
d'état où est ce que nous allons dire un
seul kane un seul septennat est ce que
nous allons continuer à voir les
législatifs juste après la
présidentielle oui il ya plein de
questions institutionnelles et donc de
les mettre en débat est nécessaire mais
ça ne réglera pas tout nécessaire dit
vous pour revivifier une démocratie
chance mantoue fatigué en tout cas ici
en france comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
ré horizontale is et le débat public ça
dont les français ont besoin selon vous
disons qu'il ya d'un côté la verticale
du pouvoir de haut en bas et d'un autre
côté l'horizontalité dont on a vu une
expression massive avec les gilet jaune
qui ne veut pas discuter avec avec la
verticalité sorte au monal si je fais un
peu de géométrie sur votre plateau et
donc la question c'est comment recréer
une culture politique du débat de l'
échange de la négociation et à la fin du
fin des fins du compromis on est très
loin de tout ça on est très très loin de
tout ça l'élysée décide ou matignon
parfois et puis il faut que ça
redescende et donc comment recréer à
tous les niveaux et à dans toutes sortes
de lieux cette capacité de de
transformer les crises les problèmes en
débat et si j'ose dire ainsi en conflit
institutionnalisée cd en conflit non
violent la démocratie c'est pas oublier
les contestations les protestations les
demandes qui viennent de la société la
démocratie c'est lé traité politiquement
et non pas du tout un posé verticalement
et l'otan bat d
des décisions ce à quoi emmanuel macron
a répondu et encore pendant cette
campagne qu'il a engagé un dialogue
direct avec les français et notamment à
l'occasion du grand débat après la crise
des gilets jaunes vaut lui est reproché
a contrario
non pas que ce vin d'abord que ce
dialogue n'est une forme de leur
dites-vous et d'autre part que et vous
lisez tout à l'heure il a participé
précisément à a enterré ce qu'on appelle
lé les corps intermédiaires écoutez wii
est le cas le plus spectaculaire c'est
sa relation avec la cfdt et celle de
l'été c'est un syndicat réformiste c'est
un syndicat qui souhaitait accompagner
le président dans des discussions des
échanges des négociations
sur la question des retraites sur la
question des gilets jaunes quoi quand
même qu'ils faisaient des propositions
et dans les deux cas fin de non recevoir
et donc c'est une catastrophe et le chef
d'état a bien compris que c'est une
catastrophe il a dit j'ai changé vous
bon donc mon livre est très respectueux
mon livre s'attendait à ce qu'il fasse
ce genre de déclaration est donc mais
mon livre est dubitatif est ce vous dire
pourquoi il ya deux raisons la première
c'est que on ne change pas comme ça de
personnalités et on peut quand même être
inquiet d'entendre quelqu'un dire je
vais me transformer tout en restant moi
même
réfléchissez un instant c'est quand même
un peu paradoxe et puis deuxièmement il
n'est pas tout seul
emmanuel macron à tout un environnement
dont à l'elysée souvent des jeunes
technocrates mais pas seulement des
ministres des cabinets d'étude et la
haute administration qui le suit et de
changer écoutez ou bien on change les
personnes ou bien on reprend les mêmes
et on leur dit ça va changer on peut
douter c'est un livre respectueux vous
dites vous dites quand même de du
maquereau nisme qu'il est une forme de
populisme oui mais le mot populiste me
permet de spécifier un certain nombre de
choses ce dont on vient de parler
l'horizontalité le refus de médiation là
le peu d'intérêt pour la représentation
l'idée qu'on est un leader un petit peu
charismatique et
finalement l'appel plus ou moins
artificiel à mon sens à des formes de
démocratie participative ou direct mais
est ce que le péché n'est pas con
partagé par les français qui attendent
de leur président précisément peut-être
trop de choses qui ont un rapport très
affectif avec leur président est
justement ce côté charismatique le
chercher
vous avez raison je pense que le
populisme c'est pas simplement telle ou
telle personnalité ni même telle ou
telle force politique c'est un un climat
assez général dans notre pays on a d'une
certaine façon du populisme d'extrême
droite nationaliste et que marine le pen
on a d'un autre côté du populisme de
gauche de la gauche avec la france
insoumise pour moi c'est un type de
populisme c'est pas l'objet aujourd'hui
mais on pourrait essayer de le montrer
et nous avons une sorte de populisme du
centre avec emmanuel macron parce que le
populisme c'est aussi un discours
mythique c'est à dire qui résout les
contradictions par le discours mais pas
dans la réalité en même temps comment
est-ce qu'on peut être en même temps à
gauche et à droite ça peut pas marcher
quand même très très très longtemps et
le populisme si ça c'est des discours
qui tient la route un certain temps pis
tient bojan se heurte à des réalités et
donc la ronde un populisme du centre est
plutôt un populisme d'en haut et pas
d'en bas en italie vous avez eu beppe
grillo le mouvement 5 étoiles ces
populisme d'en bas plutôt
populaire taille car on a plutôt des
populismes gens qui disent incarne
l'ordre la raison la façon de bien gérer
le bon management etc donc c'est plutôt
le discours des gens d'en haut et en bas
quel est le risque pour le président
réélu s'il ne change pas de culture et
de pratique politique et quel intérêt
aurait-il à le faire lui précisément qui
vient d'être réélu il faut savoir ce
qu'il veut et ce qu'ils veulent et ses
marques dans l'histoire ou pas s'il veut
laisser une marque dans l'histoire il
faut que ce soit celle d'un président
qui a reconstruit aussi la démocratie
alors on est dans une drôle de situation
aujourd'hui même on va voir des
législatifs ou bien de président à la
majorité au parlement à l'assemblée
nationale et dans ce cas là il ya peu de
chances qu'ils changent énormément les
choses
ou bien il ne l'a pas et dans ce cas là
la france est ingouvernable comment
voulez vous fabriquez une majorité avec
un centre comme celui du président une
gauche de gauche a piloté par jean luc
mélenchon et une extrême droite pour peu
qu'elles obtiennent un certain nombre de
députés ce qui est assez probable est
donc comment ces gens là pourrait-il
trouver des accords si vous allez en
allemagne vous avez 60 ou 65 % des
électeurs représenté par le pouvoir
actuel parce que trois grands partis ont
vraiment
réussi à proposer un vrai programme de
gouvernement se sont partagé les
responsabilités
c'est très clair ça marche bien mais
avec quel schéma pourrait-on imaginer en
france pour arriver à un tel compromis
et donc je suis très inquiète parce que
ou bien ça ne changera pas beaucoup
parce qu'il y aura une majorité ou bien
ce sera ingouvernable
c'est peu réjouissantes donc aujourd'hui
je suis pessimiste mais vous savez en
politique faut jamais
définitif ou péremptoires des choses
peuvent changer très très la preuve on
apprend à l'instant que le compromis
entre les socialistes et la france
insoumise est en bonne voie vous voyez
michel wieviorka merci beaucoup d'être
venu nous parler de ce livre alors
monsieur macron heureux qui est sorti
chez rue de seine donc il y a quelques
jours au lendemain du second tour de la
présidentielle il a lu le président
leurs ouvriers je les envoyais et bien
sûr je ne sais pas s'il a lu l'histoire
nous le dira l'histoire nous le dira
merci encore très bonne journée à vous